I mean I read this book and I couldn't
believe that this man LED this lifestyle
and still survived his he was incredibly
candid and and honest with me about what
he went through and a lot of times he
would we would talk about sections in
the book and he said Not only was it
that bad I was 10 times worse you have
said that that the speeches were some of
the hardest stuff for years I've been
telling you guys never to take no for an
answer right and I kind of felt like I
was Bono or some rock star even though I
knew even though I knew that these these
you know actors were paid to clap every
single time I was shouting at them I'm
not [__] leaving
you get this incessant need to you know
you know push them forward and it almost
became like this uh you know Braveheart
speech or or cry for battle except that
was persuading them to go out there and
you know essentially screw as many
people over as possible they're gonna
need a
[Applause]